she had she was about five feet tall
her hair was down to the ground she had
this like majestic chestnut hair that
was just hey Zack welcome back hey Brad
so this week you have a really
interesting piece about a female
entrepreneur who's one of the pioneers
of the franchising business model not
many people have heard about her how did
you find out about it so her name's
Martha Matilda Harper and she was kind
of she created this phenomenal business
and long before Ray Kroc McDonald's and
the whole franchise model took off she
was kind of one of the early pioneers in
this space in the late 19th century and
her story was kind of forgotten and it's
for for many years it's a footnote in
history until this woman Jane Jane
a historian resurfaced her story in the
late 90s and early 2000s and really made
a push to get her more into the
spotlight but even now today I think
relatively few younger people know about
her and she's just got kind of a very
interesting story so tell us a little
bit about her business and how she found
her niche yeah so she she started out of
life in the mid-1800s in Canada and she
was kind of born into a lower-class
family at the age of seven she was sent
away to be a house sterben by our family
and for 25 years she was house servant
and eventually she served at the house
of a physician who studied a hair
follicle science and kind of some of the
early science of hair hair treatments
and he bestowed upon her this this hair
tonic and she took that with her to
Rochester New York and eventually
found her way into certain circles saved
a little bit of money and launched a
successful franchise of hair salons at a
time when it was very difficult to even
launch a single business a female
entrepreneur she ended up growing this
into a chain of 500 stores and was was
in spirit and inspired many other women
to fall in her path
a lot of the franchise owner she hired
were other a woman who who didn't come
from upper-class backgrounds
she empowered a lot of people with
similar backgrounds to her and gave them
some freedom to run their own franchises
she sounds like a really inspiring story
to any anything you want to share just
any fun details about the business and
in the in the hair salon industry that
she was was created with yeah so she she
actually invented a number of things
like the reclining shampoo chair a sink
with a little hole cut out for the neck
just little things you see in salons
today that you don't really give much
thought to but unfortunately she didn't
secure the patents to a lot of these
inventions so it was very difficult for
her for a woman at the time to get their
name on a patent but the other funny
detail is if you if you look at there's
one old kind of iconic photograph of her
that exists she had she was about 5 feet
tall her hair was down to the ground she
had this like majestic chestnut hair
that was just like a flowing mane like
something like nothing you've ever seen
and that was actually her greatest
marketing asset is that she'd serve for
these high-class woman is a house
servant they would always ask her about
how she how her hair was so nice it was
like this incredible head of hair she
had and she used that to sell her tonic
to start her business and that was kind
of one of her one of her
chief marketing licenses use what you
have your advantage
and she certainly did that well there's
a lot more to this story you guys are
going to love this one please please
make sure you open your emails on Sunday
and thanks again for joining us
Zach thanks
you
[Music]